foreign
and the Democrats want to raise the debt
ceiling and McCarthy and Republicans
don't want to do it uh we're not going
to talk about the politics of it what
does it mean if that happens is that
something that we just kind of don't
feel George how will raising the debt
limit which is at all-time highs how
will that affect those that are
listening and watching well the this is
the idea if the U.S defaulted on its
debts meaning it can't pay the carried
interest that could cause chaos now it's
never happened and so the idea here
doesn't mean it won't it doesn't mean it
won't uh the the chances of them raising
the debt ceiling probably pretty high
because they keep doing it every year
they just keep raising the credit limit
even though this is a showdown this is a
negotiation absolutely so if you're
confused as to what this all amounts to
the debt ceiling is the amount the U.S
government can borrow to honor its
spending obligations and uh here's how
it affects you so by the way the debt
ceiling limit was 31.4 trillion and we
reached it so you know Reach for the
Stars can we at least we have a goal
there that's sad and so here's the the
few ways you could be impacted America
by the debt ceiling crisis number one is
the stock market the stock market does
not like uncertainty and defaulting on
our debts would cause the stock market
to plunge estimates uh Chief Economist
Mark Zandy said could plunge by
one-third and erase 15 trillion in
household wealth yeah that hurt that's
scary yeah that could affect a lot of
people affect a lot of your retirement
savings we do not like that the other
thing it could affect is the cost to
borrow and so a default would push
interest rates even higher so the cost
to borrow homes to get that car loan
your credit card interest rates it would
explode it would cause Mayhem the Silver
Lining there is I hope it's it stops
people from borrowing more money so
there you go uh the last thing it could
affect is Social Security and Medicare
so the debt limit fight poses several
risks to these seniors who are on Social
Security Medicare
and so without a breakthrough in
Congress the government might not be
able to send out those monthly benefit
checks or pay for Medicare so and let's
not forget the overall value of the
dollar that's true dollar has been
stronger the value it's already dropped
pretty precipitously over the last
couple days and that again affects
overall inflation and it'll hurt GDP
it'll hurt our standing globally it's a
it's a complete mess and um and I'm just
going to put this out there we'll get
back to the phones and and it could
because you the people have the power
to get these bums attention in DC
because your governor
in Most states they have to balance the
budget many states
it's a constitutional requirement for
the state to budget but excuse me to
balance
its spreadsheet I get so angry talking
about it I can't talk well you know we
don't have a balanced budget amendment
to the U.S Constitution and you know Ken
we're around here we're very fiscally
conservative and uh Congress
historically wouldn't you love to see
Dave Ramsey go to Washington for about
30 days lock all of them in a room they
only get bathroom breaks and and food
breaks I would pay to watch that on
C-Span Dave takes his just his good
old-fashioned budget
the old kitchen table sits in the middle
room yellow pad and he just starts going
through it and he would absolutely
balance the budget I believe it I know
he would I'm not kidding you I mean he
really could would Dave darken the doors
no of that building that's the question
no no I don't think he has any interest
he wouldn't last 30 minutes up there
much less 30 days than it would take but
uh there you go